РПГ
військові навчання у Чорнобильській зоні
відчуження за 8 кілометрів від кордону з
білорусью за сценарієм українські
Спецназ та штурмові підрозділи мають
стримати повторний наступ російських
військ із білоруською територією 20
січня тут задіяли важку техніку танки
БМП та самохідну артилерійську батарею
на даний час загрозу безпосередньо
сухопутних дій з боку Республіки
Білорусь то спільного угруповання яке
там знаходиться немає цей рівень низький
але ми цей час використовуємо саме для
того щоб збільшити своє оборони
спроможності зміцнити нашу оборону але
наскільки небезпечними є військові
навчання в зоні відчуження біля якої
живуть люди
якщо під час навчання там проходять
танки або стріляють то це не має жодних
наслідків для місцевого населення
це може мати наслідки хіба що для
військових які там перебувають але не
для населення
для військових пояснень експертка
важливо де саме Як довго вони перебували
в зоні відчуження найбільш заражені
місця тут у так званому у рудому лісі
після вторгнення РФ Минулого року цю
місцевість більше місяця контролювали
російські військові і вчені вважають що
вони піддалися суттєвому ризику
ми тоді провели аналіз Які наслідки це
могло б мати для російських військових
якщо вони більше місяця знаходилися в
роддому лісі Ми не можемо це точно
стверджувати але якщо вони там копали
окопи що ми бачили на відеокадрах то
вони могли отримати дуже високу дозу
радіації за нашими підрахунками понад
100 мілізівертів
при тому що природне радіаційне
опромінення в Німеччині наприклад
становить два мілізіверти на рік тобто
йшлося про значно підвищену дозу але все
ж таки не настільки щоб це відразу
задало сильної шкоди здоров'ю
українські військові ще до війни
проводили навчання у покинутому місці
Прип'ять щоб відпрацювати ведення бою в
умовах міської забудови
то там рівень радіації перевищує
наприклад радіаційне тло в Німеччині але
не дуже
у Прип'яті вже багато років проводять
екскурсії для туристів які перебували
там по кілька годин і доза радіації яку
вони там отримували була значно меншою
за ту яку Вони отримували під час
перельоту в Україну і назад
за півроку до вторгнення Росії в Україну
німецькі вчені серед яких був і Флоріан
ґерінг проводили докладні вимірювання у
зоні відчуження біля ЧАЕС
ми звісно надали результати наших
вимірювань українським чиновникам для
них це було дуже важливо для порівняння
показників до та після відходу
російських військ звідти а також для
прокладання нових маршрутів до певних
місць у зоні відчуження які раніше були
доступні лише через Білорусь
наскільки безпечними є військові
навчання в Чорнобильській зоні це
запитання кореспондентка Дольче веле
поставила на прес-конференції
міжнародного агентства затомної енергії
в Брюсселі
Вони знають про необхідність уникати
певних районів у так звані зоні
відчуження Як ви знаєте там є майданчик
із реакторами і є Так звана Зона
відчуження коли протягом короткого
періоду часу цей об'єкт був зайнятий
російськими військовими там були деякі
піки радіації через те що бронетехніка
та важкі машини російської армії
порушили верхній шар ґрунту тому я
впевнений Хоча я не маю деталей цих
маневрів Але я впевнений що українські
військові дотримуються своїх власних
правил
а також рекомендації мегате з безпеки в
плані того щоб не потрапляти в місця де
радіація все ще можливо як залишковий
Фактор після аварії 1986 року
проте німецькі вчені застерігають від
будь-яких військових дій поблизу ядерних
об'єктів
Загалом ми науковці з нерозумінням
ставимось до того що поблизу ядерних
об’єктів проводяться військові маневри
це глобальна проблема на війні в Україні
поблизу Чорнобильської зони досі є
ядерні об’єкти це хоч і неактивні
реактори але там зберігаються великі
обсяги радіоактивних матеріалів
проводити там якісь військові дії не
дуже гарна ідея тому що це збільшує
Ризик що радіоактивні речовини вийдуть
на поверхню
німецькі науковці сподіваються що коли в
Україні настане мир вони знову зможуть
провести вимірювання радіації у
Чорнобильській зоні